I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hello. Hi there. Oh, this is an exciting day. We are so pumped. Jenna and I are smiling ear to ear. This is a special episode of Office Ladies. It's a Monday motivation
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。你好。嗨。哦，今天是令人激动的一天。我们太兴奋了。珍娜和我笑得合不拢嘴。这是《办公室辣妈》的一期特别节目。这是一期周一动力节目
and we have a very exciting announcement, which is why we're smiling so big. Do it, do it, say it, lady. Okay, we are growing our company why we're smiling so big. Do it, do it, say it, lady. Okay, we are growing our company and we are now the Office Ladies Network. We're a network, yes! It's so wild even to hear you say it.
我们有一个非常让人兴奋的宣布，这就是为什么我们笑得这么灿烂。说吧，说吧，说出来，女士。好的，我们的公司正在发展为什么我们笑得这么灿烂。说吧，说吧，说出来，女士。好的，我们的公司正在发展，我们现在成了“办公室辣妈网络”。我们是一个网络了，耶！听你这么说简直太疯狂了。
Okay, here's the thing, you guys know years ago when we started this rewatch podcast, Jenna, we didn't know. We knew we were gonna to watch an episode of The Office every week, right? Yeah. We didn't even know if we'd make it through them all. We didn't know. But we are doing it and you guys have been with us every step of the way and we so appreciate it. And you know, we just love doing this podcast and we started thinking about what's in the future for Office Ladies and, well, we were like, maybe we can help our listeners find people that we also love who podcast.
好了，事情是这样的，大家知道几年前我们刚开始做这个重温播客时，珍娜，我们心里也没底。我们只知道我们每周都要看一集《办公室》，对吧？是的。我们甚至不知道自己能不能坚持把它们全部看完。我们心里没底。但我们做到了，而且大家一路陪伴着我们，我们对此非常感激。而且你知道的，我们太喜欢做这个播客了，于是我们开始思考《办公室辣妈》的未来是什么样的，然后我们就想，也许我们可以帮听众们找到那些我们同样也喜欢的做播客的人。
That's right. We want to stay in this business of podcasting. We want to expand our company. And so we have started the Office Ladies Network, and the first podcast that we are adding to our network is called The Lazy Genius. I know a lot of you already know about The Lazy Genius, especially if you follow me or Angela on Instagram. I found The Lazy Genius podcast about four years ago,
没错。我们希望继续留在播客这个行业里。我们想扩大我们的公司。所以我们成立了“办公室辣妈网络”，我们网络添加的第一个播客叫做《懒人天才》（The Lazy Genius）。我知道你们很多人已经知道《懒人天才》了，特别是如果你在Instagram上关注我和安吉拉的话。我大约四年前发现了《懒人天才》播客，
and I was immediately hooked. And as Angela can tell you, I wouldn't shut up about it. That's true. And so when we tell you, I wouldn't shut up about it. That's true. And so when we were talking about expanding into a network, it just made so much sense to reach out to Kendra and ask if she would like to join us in this adventure. You know, Jenna, you always say that Kendra would be like, if you and I had a best friendship, baby?
我一下子就被迷住了。正如安吉拉可以告诉你的那样，我简直唠叨个没完。千真万确。所以当我们谈到要扩展成一个网络时，联系肯德拉并问她是否愿意加入我们的这次冒险，简直是再顺理成章不过了。你知道，珍娜，你总是说如果我和你有了友谊结晶，那肯德拉就像是……
I don't know. Yes! We say she's like the missing link between the two of us. She's all the fun of Angela mixed with all the spreadsheets that you get with me. You know, she wants to help you organize your life in the way that works best for you,
我不知道。对！我们说她是连接我们两个人的缺失环节。她集安吉拉所有的乐趣和与我有关的所有电子表格于一身。你知道，她想以最适合你的方式帮助你整理你的生活，
but she also wants you to have fun and be relaxed while doing it. But the best person to tell you about the lazy genius is the lazy genius herself, Kendra Adachi. And we're going to talk with her about some of our favorite lazy genius principles. And Kendra is going to tell us where the office characters fall on her scale of lazy to genius. I cannot wait. I really need to hear her thoughts on Phyllis and the rest of the office gang. I mean, can you imagine Kendra
但她同时也希望你在这样做的同时能感到快乐和轻松。不过，要了解《懒人天才》，最好的人选莫过于懒人天才本人——肯德拉·足立（Kendra Adachi）。我们将与她讨论一些我们最喜欢的“懒人天才”原则。肯德拉还将告诉我们，《办公室》的角色在她的“从懒到天才”的量表上分别处于什么位置。我等不及了。我真的很想听听她对菲利斯和办公室里其他伙伴的看法。我的意思是，你能想象肯德拉
on the party planning committee, Jenna? Oh, she's the thing we've needed. I know. Well, let's take a quick break. And when we come back, Kendra Adachi, the lazy genius herself, is gonna be with us giving us some Monday motivation. You don't wanna miss it.
加入派对策划委员会吗，珍娜？哦，她正是我们一直需要的人。我知道。好了，我们先休息一下。等我们回来时，肯德拉·足立——这位懒人天才本人将做客我们的节目，给我们带来一些周一的动力。你可千万不要错过。
Oh, yeah, you're going to love it. Kendra, hello. Welcome to Office Ladies. What a treat. Oh, my goodness. This is so exciting. Oh, my God. I'm so excited. We are such big fans of yours, and we can't believe we get to have you all to ourselves today. Oh, I could say the little I'm so excited. I'm so excited. We are such big fans of yours and we can't believe we get to have you all to ourselves
哦，是的，你们一定会爱上她的。肯德拉，你好。欢迎来到《办公室辣妈》。真是荣幸。哦，天哪。太令人激动了。哦，天哪。我太兴奋了。我们是你的超级大粉丝，真不敢相信今天能独占你一人。哦，我可以说同样的—我太兴奋了。我太兴奋了。我们是你的超级大粉丝，真不敢相信今天能独占你一人
today. Oh, I could say the literal same thing. This is amazing. This is so much fun. Thank you for having me. You know what? I've realized, as I say this, I'm going to sound like such a cheese ball. But when you've heard someone in your head, like on your air pods or just in your car for so long,
今天。哦，我可以说一模一样的话。这太棒了。太有趣了。谢谢你们邀请我。你知道吗？我意识到，当我这么说的时候，听起来会像个十足的傻瓜。但是，当你在脑海中听过某个人的声音，比如在你的AirPods里或者在你的车里听了很久，
and then you're sitting there looking at the person, I realize Jen and I do this too. But I'm just looking at you and I'm like, that's her voice. And then that's her. And then she's here. I can see the mouth it's coming out of. I know. I do the same thing. Audio is like such a, such a sweet thing to be able to listen to someone. Yeah. You become friends with people so quickly. So I feel the same. I'm like, look, it's your faces saying the words.
然后你就坐在那里看着这个人，我意识到珍娜和我也会这样。但我只是看着你，心想，那是她的声音。然后那是她。然后她就在这里。我能看到声音是从哪个嘴里发出来的。我懂。我也一样。音频真是一件美好、美妙的事情，能够倾听某人的声音。是的。你很快就能和人们成为朋友。所以我的感觉也一样。我就想，看，是你们的脸在说出那些话。
Look right down. That I hear. I know. It's so fun. Well, Kendra, we love your podcast, The Lazy Genius, and we would love for you to tell our audience, what is a lazy genius? A lazy genius is someone who is a genius about the things that matter and lazy about the things that don't. So the thing that the problem is that there are a lot of voices that are telling us all the different things that should matter and we want
看下面。我听到的声音。我知道。太有趣了。好吧，肯德拉，我们非常喜欢你的播客《懒人天才》，我们希望你能告诉我们的听众，什么是“懒人天才”？懒人天才就是一个对重要的事情精益求精（是个天才），对不重要的事情顺其自然（很懒）的人。所以，问题在于，有很多声音在告诉我们所有应该重要的事情，而我们想
to be like good rule followers and like decent people and we're like, okay, well, this should matter. I'll work hard on this. I'll do this thing. And then we just like end up with adrenal fatigue. It's like a whole thing. So I want to give people permission to choose what matters to them based on their own lives and their own seasons of life and their personalities and their families and all of that. And then put energy into things that matter to them. Like, it's not that you have to, like, messy here, don't care your entire life away. You can care about stuff. You can be good at stuff. Like, I think that's a wonderful thing.
成为那种遵纪守规矩的好公民和正派的人，于是我们就会想：“好吧，这一定很重要。我要在这上面努力。我要做这件事。”然后我们最终落得个肾上腺素耗尽的下场。这简直是一整套的东西。所以我想给人们一种许可，让他们根据自己的生活、生活的不同阶段、他们的个性以及他们的家庭等等来选择对他们真正重要的东西。然后把精力投入到对他们重要的事情上。这并不是说你必须得……比如，把你的整个生活都搞得一团糟、毫不在乎。你完全可以关心事物。你完全可以擅长某些事情。比如，我认为这是一件很美好的事情。
You want to be a genius at certain things in your life. But in order to do that, you also got to let some other stuff go. You got to be lazy about some stuff. And I just give people principles to help do that in their own way. And then also, I have this podcast that kind of breaks it down topically to kind of help you be a lazy genius about whatever the thing is. And so it's, I've been doing that for, I've been teaching people how to be a lazy genius since 2016. Well, Kendra, the very first podcast I heard of yours was called Something Like How to Organize Paper in Your Home. Oh, she talked about that so much, Kendra.
你想成为生活中某些方面的天才。但为了做到这一点，你还得放下一些别的东西。你必须在某些事情上当个“懒人”。我只是提供一些原则，帮助人们以他们自己的方式做到这一点。而且，我还有这个播客，它从各个主题进行分解，旨在帮助你在任何事情上都能成为一个懒人天才。所以，我一直在这样做，自2016年以来我一直在教人们如何成为一个懒人天才。好吧，肯德拉，我听过的你的第一个播客叫做类似《如何整理家中的文件》这样的节目。哦，她跟人唠叨这个可多次了，肯德拉。
All the paper that comes in your home. And this was my introduction to you. I didn't really know what a lazy genius was yet. And so when I clicked on that podcast, I thought you were going to literally prescribe to me what to do with all the papers that come into my house. All of my kids' artwork, all of the school forms, all of the insurance follow-up from when you go to the doctor, all the things that accumulate in a pile or multiple piles. And to my surprise, you did not tell me what to do with the paper. You asked me what mattered to me about these piles of paper. And it was such this light bulb for me because you're right. I watch Instagram and there's all these videos of special frames that I can put my kids' artwork in and I'm like, should I be doing that? Should I be buying the frames where I cycle the different paintings in and out?
所有涌入你家的文件。这就是我认识你的开始。我当时还不太了解什么是“懒人天才”。所以当我点击那个播客时，我以为你 literalmente（字面意义上）会给我开出一剂药方，告诉我该如何处理家里所有的文件。我所有孩子的艺术作品、所有的学校表格、你去医院看病所有的保险后续单据，所有那些堆成一堆或好几堆的东西。出乎我的意料，你并没有告诉我该怎么处理这些文件。你问我，关于这些厚厚的文件堆，什么对我来说才是重要的。这对我来说就像是一盏点亮的明灯，因为你是对的。我刷Instagram，上面全都是各种特殊的相框的视频，我可以把孩子们的艺术作品放进去，然后我就想：我是不是该这么做？我是不是该买那种可以把不同的画作轮流替换进去的相框？
I tried it. I never cycled a single thing. And what I learned from your podcast Kendra was that a lot of that paper didn't matter to me and I could let it go. It was okay. If we looked at a piece of the artwork and we appreciated it, and then we let it go. And it was great. It was very freeing because you helped me name what did matter to me about it. And then you helped me allow myself to be lazy about the other parts. And it was transformative. It really was. And it was so simple. But you do that on your podcast all the time.
我试过。我一张画也从来没有轮换过。而我从你的播客中学到的是，肯德拉，许多这样的纸张对我来说并不重要，我可以放手不管。没关系。如果我们看了一件艺术作品，欣赏了它，然后就让它过去吧。这感觉太棒了。这非常具有解放意义，因为你帮我明确了什么对我来说才是真正重要的。然后你帮我允许自己在其他部分偷懒。这真的具有变革性的意义。确实如此。而且它是如此简单。但你在你的播客中一直在这样做。
You did one about packing school lunches that changed my life. I'm so glad. And here's the thing that I think is so vital to this is your decision to go, we're gonna look at this paper and go, yes, this was so lovely. Into the recycling it goes. You are just as, cause we're going to look at this paper and go, yes, this was so lovely. Into the recycling it goes.
你做过一期关于打包学校午餐的节目，彻底改变了我的生活。我太高兴了。而且我认为这其中最至关重要的一点是，你决定说：“我们要看一眼这张纸，然后说：‘好的，这太可爱了。’然后把它扔进回收站。”你同样是……因为我们要看一眼这张纸，然后说：“好的，这太可爱了。扔进回收站。”
You are just as, because we're talking about like in that context kids artwork, like you're just as good of a mother as someone who cycles through the artwork. Like we have this sort of, it's almost like a gas gauge, you know, of like, we have to be all things. We, it's like a full tank in order to be a full tank of this kind of person. You have to care this way. And that's just not the way it goes. And so I just love that you're like,
你同样是……因为我们谈论的是那种情况下的儿童艺术品，就像你和一个把艺术品轮流换框的母亲一样，是一个同样优秀的母亲。我们有这种类似于油表的东西，你知道的，就好像，我们必须面面俱到。我们，这就好象必须加满油。为了成为那种油量全满的人，你必须以这种特定的方式去在乎。但事情根本不是这样的。所以我真的很高兴你说，
we're going to look at this and go, remember this, this was so fun. But we don't have to keep it in order for that experience to matter. So I'm so glad. You're right. And that's what the entire show, all 300 something episodes at this point, it really
我们要看一眼这个然后说：记住这个，这太好玩了。但为了让这段经历保持意义，我们并不需要把它留着。所以我太高兴了。你说得对。而这正是整个节目，到目前为止所有300多期节目的核心所在，它确实
does. I really want to help you see more than help you figure out what to do. You have to see it your way first before you can do anything anyway. So just try to set you up with like the right pair of glasses, you know? What I like about it too is that you let everyone approach it their way. It's not, there's no one path to like, how do we save art? How do we appreciate our kids' art in that pile of paper? And I never feel like whatever choice I make is less than because it's my choice. And it's, it's what makes us happy as a family, what makes
我真的很想帮你去“看清”，而不是帮你去“决定该做什么”。无论如何，在你在做任何事情之前，你必须先以自己的方式看待它。所以只是试着为你配上一副合适的眼镜，你知道吗？我也很喜欢这一点，那就是你让每个人都以自己的方式去对待。这并不是说，只有唯一一条途径去教我们如何保存艺术品，或者如何在纸堆中欣赏我们孩子的艺术。而且我从来不觉得无论我做出什么选择就低人一等，因为那是我的选择。而且，这是能让我们作为一家人感到快乐、让我们
us work. And I just love that because, you know, sometimes people will tell you how to do something and there's this implied thing of like, and this is how it's done. But that's not the case at all. I just love it. We love you. We're your fan club, lady. We are your fan club.
能够顺利运转的东西。我太喜欢这个了，因为，你知道，有时人们会告诉你该怎么做，其中隐含着一种意思是：“事情就该这么做。”但事实根本不是这样。我太喜欢了。我们爱死你了。我们是你的粉丝团，女士。我们是你的粉丝团。
It's so nice. It's so nice. You guys, the angel will just call me lady. You've been ladies. She's been ladies. It's like Paul's handshake on Bake Off. It's like, I just got ladies. It's like Paul's handshake on bank off. It's like, I just got ladies. You got the Paul Hollywood.
太好了。太好了。你们这些家伙，安吉拉总是叫我女士。你们一直是女士。她一直在叫女士。这就像《英国家庭烘焙大赛》上保罗（·好莱坞）的握手一样。就像是，我刚刚得到了“女士”称号。这就像保罗在烘焙大赛上的握手。就像是，我刚刚得到了“女士”。你得到了保罗·好莱坞的认可。
Kendra, we're really curious. How did you become the lazy genius? Oh, yeah. What's your origin story? My origin story. Well, it was been by a radioactive spider. No. I actually, I have always been a very responsible old soul. Like
肯德拉，我们真的很好奇。你是怎么成为懒人天才的？哦，是的。你的起源故事是什么？我的起源故事。嗯，是被一只放射性蜘蛛咬了。不。其实，我一直是个非常负责任的老灵魂。就像
my friends in middle school and high school called me mom. I was voted most dependable by my senior class. Like I was not fun at parties, but I was like really, I could really help you figure out a homework strategy that would get you through school. So I've always really loved finding ways to do things. I love finding systems for things and making things kind of efficient, but I had not yet gone to therapy. And so I really started out just being a natural trying to be a genius at everything. And what that meant was that I didn't try anything new. I just was like, I'm going to, if I can't be awesome at this,
我在初中和高中的朋友们叫我妈妈。我被我的毕业班评为最值得信赖的人。我虽然在派对上一点也不好玩，但我真的很……我真的能帮你找出能让你顺利完成学业的家庭作业策略。所以我一直很喜欢寻找做事的方法。我喜欢为事情寻找系统，让事情变得高效，但我当时还没有去做过心理治疗。所以我的起点其实只是一个试图在每件事上都做到完美的天才。这意味着我不敢尝试任何新事物。我只是觉得：“如果我做不到最好，
I'm not gonna do it. And so I swung this one direction of like, I'm gonna be amazing at everything. And then I had my first kid and I realized like, oh wow, trying to be good at everything when you have a human baby that you have to tend to. This is tough. This is a tough look.
那我就不干了。”所以我走向了这样一个极端：我要在每件事上都表现得惊艳。然后我有了第一个孩子，我意识到，哦，天啊，当你必须照顾一个活生生的人类婴儿时，还想在每件事上都表现得优秀，这太难了。这可真是不好办。
But I tried real hard. I had a, y'all. I had a y'all I had a calendar on my fridge that was a year. It was a full annual January to December. And I made a cleaning schedule for an entire year on a year that I had a baby. What on or that is that is genius energy going in the wrong direction. That's genius energy without any sort of temporary, and that's like, wow, girlfriend, you need to calm down. You need to go take a nap.
但我真的很努力。大家伙们，我当时有一个。我有一个。我冰箱上挂着一个日历，是一整年的。是一整年从一月到十二月的。我居然在一个刚生完孩子的年份里，做了一整年的清洁时间表。这是……这简直是把天才的能量用错了方向。那是毫无缓冲的天才能量，简直就像是：“哇，女朋友，你需要冷静一下。你需要去睡个午觉。”
Well, then I had a second kid two years later, and I swung the other direction, where I was like, well, I don't care about anything. If I can't make any of this work, I'm not gonna care about any of it. And then I was also kind of sad, because like, I care about things. I wanna do good work and things.
好吧，两年后我又有了第二个孩子，然后我走向了另一个极端，我觉得，好吧，我对什么都不在乎了。如果我没法把这一切都搞定，那我就什么都不在乎了。然后我也变得有点难过，因为，我很在乎事情。我想做好工作和各种事情。
I want to like put time and energy into stuff that matters to me, but I didn't have the language for that difference yet. So I was just, I was just like swinging like this rulf caffeinated pendulum of like genius, lazy, genius, lazy. It was really intense. And then I had a third kid and I guess I have like these big life realizations when I have children and thought there's got to be a better way. Like I don't have to keep going to these extremes.
我想把时间和精力投入到对我很重要的事情上，但我当时还没有词汇来表达这种区别。所以我就像一个摄入了过多咖啡因的钟摆一样疯狂摆动：天才、懒惰、天才、懒惰。这真的太抓马了。然后我又有了第三个孩子，我想我大概是在生孩子的时候会有这种人生大彻大悟，心想：一定有更好的办法。我不需要一直走到这些极端。
What if I was a genius about the things that I care about, but I could let the other stuff go and I was doing some work on the internet already just in a different category and just pivoted the business to this where I started to talk about this, because this was such a common problem among women especially, because we're told to care, you do it all. You have it all, you be it all, you know? And we can't, we literally can't, but the alternative is not to just give up.
如果我只对我真正在乎的事情当个天才，而把其他事情放手不管会怎样呢？当时我已经在互联网上从事一些其他类别的创作了，于是就把业务重心转向了这个方向，开始谈论这个话题，因为这尤其是女性中一个非常普遍的问题，因为我们被告知要去在乎，你要做到这一切。你拥有一切，你成为一切，你知道吗？但我们做不到，我们字面意义上做不到，然而唯一的选择并不是就此放弃。
It's not try hard or give up. Those are not your two options. Your option is you can be a lazy genius. So that's where the actual kind of business started, as I wanted to create a language for people and permission for people to not do what I did, which is lose their minds trying to create an annual cleaning schedule or never cleaning their house at all. You know, it's like, huh, I feel like there's a third, there's a third path here. Let's find it. And who knows what will happen if you have a fourth baby? Listen, after I know, after this podcast set in, I was like, okay, babe, I think,
并不是“努力奋斗”或者“直接放弃”。这不是你的两个仅有的选项。你的选项是：你可以成为一个懒人天才。这就是我真正开展这项业务的初衷，我想为人们创造一种语言，并给予人们一种许可，让他们不要去做我做过的事情——为了制定一份年度清洁时间表而精神崩溃，或者干脆从来不打扫屋子。你知道，这就好像是：呃，我觉得这里应该有第三种，应该有第三种途径。让我们把它找出来。谁知道如果你生第四个孩子会发生什么？听着，我知道，在这期播客录完后，我就想：好吧，宝贝，我想，
snip snip, no more babies. I think we're set. We did it. We did it. We found that middle ground. Okay. So, Kendra, we're very excited to ask you about the office characters and where they would fall on your scale of lazy to genius. So, I think a great way to kind of humanize this idea is, I wanna actually talk about Angela. Angela Martin. Like Angela Martin, yes. Okay. Cause listen, Angela is all genius, no lazy. Like we all know this. Like she's just, this is how it's done.
咔嚓咔嚓（结扎），不要再有小孩了。我想我们定下来了。我们做到了。我们找到了那个中间地带。好的。那么，肯德拉，我们非常高兴向你询问关于《办公室》角色的问题，看看他们在你的“从懒到天才”的量表上会落在哪里。所以，我认为将这个理念人性化的一个好方法是，我其实想谈谈安吉拉。安吉拉·马丁。就像安吉拉·马丁，对。好的。因为听着，安吉拉完全是天才，一点也不懒。我们都知道这一点。就像她会觉得：事情就该这么做。
This is what you should care about. And no one else is going to tell her otherwise, right? Like it's absolutely. Is Angela lazy about anything? Like, I don't know, and maybe fun. Maybe she's lazy about fun. Maybe she's lazy at fun. No, I think she's all genius,
这就是你应该在乎的。而且没有人能跟她唱反调，对吧？绝对是这样。安吉拉对什么事情是懒惰的吗？比如，我不知道，也许是乐趣。也许她对乐趣很懒。也许她在玩乐方面很懒。不，我觉得她完全是个天才，
except when she moved, she had that patch where her and the senator broke up and she wasn't sure where she was gonna live and she came into the office all disheveled, her hair everywhere with like a giant, like one of those like big 7-Eleven slurpee cup things. Do you remember it? And your clothes were-
除了她搬家那段时期，她和参议员分手了，她不确定自己要住在哪里，她来到办公室时衣衫褴褛，头发乱蓬蓬的，手里拿着一个巨大的、类似于7-Eleven思乐冰的那种大杯子。你还记得吗？你的衣服是……
I never loved Angela more than in that moment. Cause it was like, oh, she's breaking. She's doing it. She's breaking the facade. And I will tell you that screen grab image of how she walks into the office that day. People send it to me like how I'm feeling right now and I'm like, oh, okay. I'm a I guess I'm a meme but
我从来没有像那一刻那样深爱过安吉拉。因为那感觉就像是，哦，她要崩溃了。她在这么做。她在打破那种伪装。我必须告诉你，那天她走进办公室时的那个视频截屏。人们经常把它发给我，配上“这就是我现在的感受”，然后我就想：好吧，看来我成了一个表情包，但是
Yeah, I think she after her second yeah, I would say I think that means sums it up And then when she broke she went hard the other way 100% Okay, Jenna. Where do you think Pam is on the lazy genius scale? What would you say? You know, I think she is a pretty good lazy genius. I'll be curious what your assessment is, but I feel like she has a pretty good balance and she's also relatively flexible. Yeah, I think the same. I think she's like, if you're looking at it like a sort of like a gas gauge with genius on one side and lazy on the other, I think she skews more genius than
是的，我觉得她经历了第二次……是的，我会说那个表情包总结了一切。然后当她崩溃时，她走向了另一个极端，百分之百。好的，珍娜。你觉得帕姆在懒人天才量表上处于什么位置？你会怎么说？你知道，我觉得她是个相当不错的懒人天才。我很好奇你的评估是什么，但我觉得她保持了相当不错的平衡，而且她也相对比较灵活。是的，我也这么觉得。我觉得她就像是，如果你把它看作是一个油表，一头是天才，另一头是懒惰，我觉得她比
lazy, but she's like much more, she's a lot closer to the middle. And I think one of the biggest reasons is that I think she actually really wants to be a lazy genius. It's more that she really cares what other people think a lot. And when we think we care, it's totally normal to care what other people think and wanna adjust and respond to that. But like if you're doing that over and over again
懒惰更偏向天才一点，但她更……她离中间位置近得多。而且我认为其中最大的原因之一是，我觉得她其实真的很想成为一个懒人天才。更多是因为她真的很在乎别人的看法。当我们觉得我们在乎时，在乎别人的看法并想要做出调整和回应是完全正常的。但是，如果你一遍又一遍地这样做，
at the expense of what matters to you, that's why I like we all love when she walked across the coals because it was like I'm doing this for me like no one's telling me that I'm gonna do this for me and that and then like coming alive in that moment like was such a such a lovely thing but yeah I think I think Pam's actually like she's not in my opinion the most lazy genius person in the office but she's pretty close she's actually pretty close I actually said I said out loud one time when I was watching the office I said man I wish out loud one time when I was watching the office, I said,
却牺牲了真正对你重要的东西，这就是为什么我们都喜欢她赤脚走过炭火的那一幕，因为那感觉就像是：“我在为自己做这件事，没有人告诉我……我要为我自己做这件事。”那一刻她整个人都活过来了，简直太美妙了……但是的，我觉得帕姆其实……在我看来，她不是办公室里最“懒人天才”的人，但她非常接近了，她其实非常接近。我曾经有一次在看《办公室》的时候大声说出来，我说，天哪，
man, I wish Pam would read my book. I think Pam would really benefit from it. I think Pam would really benefit from it. Who do you think is the most lazy genius? Cause you said you had one. I do. I think it's Phyllis. Really?
真希望帕姆能读读我的书。我觉得帕姆会从中获益匪浅的。我觉得帕姆会从中获益匪浅的。你觉得谁才是最典型的懒人天才？因为你说过你有一个人选。我确实觉得。我觉得是菲利斯。真的吗？
I do. Oh, I'm seeing it. I think it's Phyllis. It's coming into focus for me. Yes. Because she's so like confident in what she wants to do and how she does it. I actually think this is this kind of a strange thing. I think Phyllis is the most lazy genius because, yeah,
我真的是这么觉得的。哦，我开始看出来了。我觉得是菲利斯。这在我脑海中逐渐清晰起来了。是的。因为她对自己想做什么以及如何去做充满了自信。我其实觉得——这听起来可能有点奇怪——我真的觉得菲利斯才是最典型的懒人天才，因为，是的，
she cares where she needs to care. She doesn't mind letting things go when she wants to. Like she's going to pick her fights with Angela in whatever way she's like, I don't have time when she wants to, like she's gonna pick her fights with Angela in whatever way, you know, she's like, I don't have time for this, whatever, like just leaving. But I also think someone who else is kind of a lazy genius, but who doesn't have like a Bob Vance
她只在需要上心的地方上心。当她想放手时，她不介意放下事情。比如，她会以某种方式跟安吉拉据理力争，她心里会想：“我才没时间和这个扯呢。”无论如何，她就像是：“我没空管这破事儿，随便啦”，然后直接走人。不过我也觉得，还有一个人也挺像懒人天才的，但就是没有一个像鲍勃·万斯那样
to love him into confidence is Toby. I think Toby, if loved well, I think Toby would be such a great lazy genius. You know who is like, almost doesn't fit. You know who is like almost doesn't fit? There are three people who almost don't fit on the scale at all. And it's Michael, Ryan, and Kelly, because they, all three of them, in my assessment, and I'm curious what you think about this, they want to be geniuses about the things that matter to them,
用爱来滋养他自信的人，那就是托比。我觉得托比如果能被好好爱护的话，他一定会成为一个绝佳的懒人天才。你知道谁简直是……几乎完全不符合吗？你知道谁几乎完全不符合吗？有三个人几乎完全不符合这个量表，那就是迈克尔、瑞恩和凯利，因为他们三个人，据我的评估——我很好奇你们对此怎么看——他们想要在对他们重要的事情上成为天才，
but those things matter to literally no one else. And so they're just like bulldozing through the room, and you're like, what are we even, no one else cares about this right now, Michael, what are we doing? What's happening? It's so unsettling, which is what made it great TV. But yeah, I had a hard time characterizing the three of them.
但那些事情对其他人来说简直毫无意义。所以他们只是像推土机一样横冲直撞地穿过房间，而你就会想：“我们在干什么呀？根本没有人在乎这个好吗，迈克尔，我们在干什么？这到底是怎么回事？”这太让人摸不头脑了，这也是为什么它是极好的电视剧。但说实话，我很难给这三个人进行准确定性。
They're like all through below the scale. They're like in their own. They're all over it. Yes, they are. Well, I think they definitely want to be geniuses about things they think are important, but like you said, aren't. And then they have no follow through.
他们简直就像是……完全在量表刻度之外。他们自成一派。是的，他们确实如此。好吧，我觉得他们绝对想在自认为很重要的事情上成为天才，但就像你说的，其实并不重要。而且他们完全没有后续的执行力。
So that's the problem. They're not going to do any work to get to that genius place. Yeah, it's pretty great. I think two geniuses that end up together are Dwight and Angela. Yes. And I'm always curious when people say, do you think Dwight and Angela are still together? How do you think that's going? I'm like, they either had a war of the Roses moment or they are running the country. You know what I mean? Like, that's right. That's right.
所以问题就在这里。他们根本不会付出任何努力来达到那种“天才”的境界。是的，这太棒了。我觉得最终走到一起的两个天才就是德怀特和安吉拉。是的。每次人们问：“你觉得德怀特和安吉拉现在还在一起吗？你觉得他们过得怎么样？”我都很好奇。我就说，他们要么经历了一场《玫瑰战争》式的决裂，要么他们现在正在统治这个国家。你知道我的意思吗？对的，没错。
There's not a lot of middle ground there. No. They're taking over everything or they're no longer together. Yeah, exactly. Well, Kendra, you have done this amazing thing where you have created for us a visual scale of where all of the office characters
那里面可没有什么折中的灰色地带。没有。要么他们接管了一切，要么他们早就分道扬镳了。是的，完全如此。好吧，肯德拉，你做了一件了不起的事情，为我们制作了一个视觉量表，展示了《办公室》里的所有角色
fall on the lazy to genius spectrum. And that is over on your website, thelazygeniuscollective.com. Everyone should go check it out. Angela, you're going to put it in our Instagram stories. I am. And shout out to Ileana who helped us with the artwork for that. But it's great. Office fans, you need to see it. It's pretty fun. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we are super excited to share
在“从懒到天才”的谱系上分别处于什么位置。这个量表就在你的网站上：thelazygeniuscollective.com。大家都应该去看看。安吉拉，你会把它发到我们的Instagram快拍上的。我会的。向伊莱亚娜（Ileana）致敬，她帮我们设计了其中的插图。真的很棒。办公室的粉丝们，你们一定要去看看。挺好玩的。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们非常高兴与大家分享
about a particular lazy genius episode that changed our work life, me and Angela, and it also deepened our friendship, and we wanna talk to you about it. We'll be right back. We are back and Kendra were super excited to share about how one particular episode of the Lazy Genius transformed our work life. Angela, tell Kendra what it was. Okay.
关于一个特定的“懒人天才”剧集，它改变了我和安吉拉的工作生活，它还加深了我们的友谊，我们想跟你们聊聊这个。我们马上回来。我们回来了，肯德拉，我们非常高兴能分享一期特别的《懒人天才》播客是如何改变我们的工作生活的。安吉拉，告诉肯德拉那是哪一集。好的。
Well, it was episode 297 titled five things for more ease at work. And it really, really changed how I approach emails, which was a stumbling block for me for a long, long time. Kendra, so long. I'm sad I hadn't listened to this episode years ago. I'm so thankful. I'm sad she hadn't listened to it years ago. Just wait, Jen's going to let you know. But it really changed how I approach emails so thankful. She hadn't listened to it, her second. Just wait, Jim's gonna let you know. But it really changed how I approached emails so much.
嗯，那是第297集，标题是《提升工作轻松感的五件事》。它真的、真的很彻底地改变了我处理电子邮件的方式，这曾是我很长一段时间以来的绊脚石。肯德拉，太久了。我很遗憾自己没有早几年听这期节目。我太感激了。我很遗憾她没有早几年听这期节目。等着瞧吧，珍娜会让你知道的。但它真的极大地改变了我处理电子邮件的方式，我太感激了。她竟然没听过，等一会儿。等着瞧吧，珍娜会让你知道的。但它真的彻底改变了我处理电子邮件的方式。
And it was so obvious once I listened how I was looking at it wrong. Anyway, I just wanna share with you about how that affected our work life. Yeah, so what was, cause I have no idea what, I did not know about this. So this is a surprise to me. So I'm so excited.
而且一旦我听了，就会发现自己以前的看法错得多么离谱，这是显而易见的。总之，我只是想跟你分享一下那对我俩工作生活的影响。好的，那么，因为我完全不知道是哪一集，我对此一无所知。所以这对我来说是个惊喜。我太兴奋了。
So what was your relationship with your inbox like before the episode and maybe how that was in work? Like what did it look like before and what does it look like after? Okay. Well, this is, this is like, show me the scary nook in your closet. But, okay. Here's the thing.
那么，在听这期节目之前，你与收件箱的关系是怎样的？这在工作中大概是什么样的？比如，之前是什么样子的，之后又是什么样子的？好吧。嗯，这就像是——“快展示一下你衣橱里那个吓人的角落吧”。不过，好吧。事情是这样的。
Right now it says I have 2,333 emails. I'm not gonna cry about that. It's all fine. It gives me heart palpitations. That's a big red number, Angela. Okay, it's a big number, but it was like 7,000. So there are a lot of like backlog emails now that are just spamming crap
就在刚才，它显示我有2,333封未读邮件。我才不会为此哭呢。一切都好。这看得我心脏都要怦怦直跳了。那可是个很大的红字提示啊，安吉拉。好吧，这数字确实很大，但它以前可是7,000封呢。所以现在里面有很多积压的邮件，全都是垃圾广告，
that are taking me forever to get rid of. But whenever I have like a long flight or something like that, I'm going through and I'm unsubscribing from things and you know stuff just the clutter. But where it really helped me was with my day in, day out work emails. Jen and I at any time have multiple projects going on. And the toughest thing for me wasn't just so much how much I hate email because I hate email, but trying to understand what was a priority when you have multiple projects and multiple things. Because I'm much better at school emails. They sort of make sense to me because they have a real timely manner to them. And it's very easy for me to understand
花了我好长时间才清理干净。但每当我坐长途航班或者类似的时候，我就会顺便浏览并取消订阅各种东西，你知道的，就是清理那些杂物。不过它真正帮到我的地方，是在我日复一日的工作邮件上。珍娜和我随时都有多个项目在进行。对我来说最难的不仅仅是我有多讨厌电子邮件——因为我是真的很讨厌电子邮件，而是当你有多个项目和很多事情要处理时，去搞清楚什么才是优先事项。因为我在处理学校邮件方面要好得多。那些对我有一定意义，因为它们有很强的时效性，
what's a priority and what's not. But with our work emails, that was a struggle for me. And you talk about five top things for more ease at work and the first one is prioritize, then it's essentialize, organize, personalize and systemize. But because I couldn't prioritize my work emails, I couldn't get to any of the other steps. And I was drowning in them. And it was
我非常容易分清什么事是当务之急，什么事不是。但在我们的工作邮件上，这对我来说是个挣扎。而你谈到了提高工作轻松感的五大要点，第一点是“优先排序”，然后是“精简”、“组织”、“个性化”和“系统化”。但因为我无法对我的工作邮件进行优先排序，所以我根本无法推进到任何后续的步骤。我在邮件海洋中灭顶了。这
affecting my work life and Jenna's work life when she needed something that was a timely answer for her, but I didn't understand it was timely. And that, you know, that really was something that she shared with me that finally she hit her breaking point was like, Angie, I spent all this time on this email, you haven't checked it for like four days. And that's not okay. I put a lot of work into that. And I was gutted because I love her so much. And I take such pride in our business partnership and our friendship. And so, for me, the idea that me not understanding that she needed an answer so quickly and then me not being able
严重影响了我的工作生活，也影响了珍娜的工作生活——当她需要一个及时的回复时，而我却根本没意识到那是具有时效性的。而且，你知道，这确实是她后来跟我分享的，她终于达到了崩溃的边缘，就说：“安吉拉，我在这个邮件上花了那么多时间，你居然晾了它足足四天都没看。”这太不应该了。我在上面倾注了大量的心血。我当时心碎欲绝，因为我太爱她了。我为我们的业务合作伙伴关系和我们的友谊感到无比自豪。所以，对我来说，一想到我没有意识到她那么快就需要一个答复，然后我又找不到了——因为邮件现在已经落入了未读邮件的无底深渊中，
to find it because now it had like fallen into the abyss of open emails. And I panicked and I also felt horrible because I wouldn't ever want her to not feel valued in our relationship in any way and me not checking that email. But it was a buffet. It was years and months of me not being on top of this. This is such a great example of something that happens in relationships all over the place when you and someone that you love have different priorities about the same thing and you haven't named that yet, it does, it can cause so much chaos. And you're like, what just happened?
我当时恐慌了，而且我感觉糟糕透了，因为我绝不希望她有任何一刻觉得自己在我们的关系中没有被重视，而这一切都是因为我没有去查看那封邮件。但这就像是一个自助餐，这是我几个月甚至几年没有掌控好局面的结果。这真是一个极好的例子，展示了当事人和你所爱的人对同一件事情有着不同的优先级，而你们还没来得及说清楚时，在各种人际关系中经常发生的情况。这确实会导致那么多的混乱。然后你就会想：刚刚到底发生什么了？
It's just fill in the blank. It's just email, it's just laundry, it's just pickup, it's just whatever, but that's why that first step is to prioritize because if you try to organize your inbox before you name what matters about it and before you actually essentialize and be like, what's in the way here? If you try to organize things you don't need, you're going to crawl in a hole, you're going to go off the grid, and you're never going to be on email again.
这不过就是填空题罢了，这不过就是邮件，不过就是洗衣服，不过就是接送孩子，不过就是随便什么事，但这就是为什么第一步是要进行优先级排序，因为如果你试图在弄清楚什么才是真正重要的之前去整理你的收件箱，在真正去精简并找出“到底是什么挡了路”之前去整理——如果你试图去整理那些你根本不需要的东西，你最后只会钻进地洞里、与世隔绝，然后就再也不会打开电子邮件了。
And it's so frustrating when, yeah, when we have a different priority than someone we love, but we just haven't said it out loud yet. So the saying it out loud, it sounds like that was like a huge thing, is being able to name that together. I love that. Well, for me, the thing is, is that I know in our business,
当……是的，当我们与所爱之人的优先级不一致，但我们又没有大声说出来时，这真的太令人沮丧了。所以把话说出来，听起来就像是一件大事，能够把这些共同明确下来。我太喜欢了。好吧，对我来说，情况是这样的，我深知在我们的事业中，
from the moment we started the business, that we had the same interest in the business, we valued it the same, we have the same work ethic ethic we put family first we have this creative energy. So all of our broad strokes are very aligned but when we started to get into the nitty gritty of how we like to each work how we're most effective doing the work we're so different and i know that Angela is best with text and audio message. I'm a dinosaur. I just want to talk to you. Yes. This is the best way for her to process is to speak it. I love to type it and see it and read it over and get it perfect and then send it. And the problem was that for the most part, I could adjust how I worked to this
从我们创业的第一天起，我们对这项事业就有着相同的兴趣，我们赋予它相同的价值，我们有相同的工作伦理，我们把家庭放在第一位，我们拥有这种创造性的能量。所以我们的整体大方向是非常一致的。但当我们开始陷入那些细枝末节——关于我们每个人喜欢如何工作、如何以最高效的方式完成工作时，我们的分歧就太大了。我知道安吉拉最擅长发短信和语音消息。我简直是个老古董。我只想跟你说话。是的。对她来说最好的处理方式就是说出来。我喜欢把它打出来、看一看、读上几遍、把它做到完美然后再发送。问题在于，在大多数情况下，
texting audio way of messaging. And we were making it work and we figured it out. But from time to time, I needed it in an email. That was the best way for me to organize my thoughts and for me to also like have it as a tangible thing that I could find later because my email system is very clear to me and I don't lose things in an abyss in the same way. But what was getting frustrating is if I sent Angela
我可以调整自己的工作方式，去适应这种发短信和发语音消息的方式。我们一直在努力让它行之通，我们也确实搞定了。但偶尔，我还是需要一封电子邮件。那是对我来说整理思绪的最佳方式，也让我能拥有一件有形的、以后还能找得到的物件，因为我的电子邮件系统对我来说非常清晰，我也不会像掉进无底深渊那样把东西弄丢。但令人沮丧的是，如果我给安吉拉
an email in order to get a response like a few days later, I would have to text her that I sent Angela an email in order to get a response, like a few days later, I would have to text her that I sent her an email and maybe resend the email to put it at the top of the 7,000 messages. And I eventually said, I don't think that's fair. I don't think I should have to do that. Remind you that I already emailed you. Yes, because that's extra work for me. And I really heard that, I really you that I already emailed you. Yes, because that's extra work for me. And I really heard that.
发了一封电子邮件，为了得到回复——往往要过好几天，我都必须再给她发短信告诉她我给她发过邮件了，为了能得到一个回复，我甚至得重新发一遍邮件，好把它置顶在那7,000条未读消息的最上面。我最终不得不说，我觉得这太不公平了。我觉得我不应该做这种事——还得提醒你我已经给你发过邮件了。对，因为这对我来说是额外的工作。我真的听进去了，我真的听进去了。
I really heard that. And I hadn't thought about it because we text so much, and sometimes we'll be like, oh, remember that thing we talked about last week? Or so-and-so emailed us, we haven't answered that. So it was sort of jumbled and all that, but what I wasn't seeing was how it affected her on a regular basis. I knew that it wasn't seeing was how it affected her on a regular basis, you know?
我真的听进去了。我以前根本没想过这一点，因为我们发短信发得太频繁了，有时我们会说：“哦，还记得我们上周聊的那件事吗？”或者“某某给我们发邮件了，我们还没回呢。”所以事情往往混杂在一起，诸如此类。但我当时没有看到的是，这经常对她造成了什么影响。我当时并没有看到它对她常规工作的影响，你知道吗？
I knew that it wasn't because Angela didn't care. Sure. It wasn't because she didn't value me or our work. I knew that this was in the nitty gritty. This was in the like, emails don't work for her. And so when she listened to your episode and figured out a way to make emails work for her. And now my emails like get seen. It was so transformative and exciting. Cause I told Angela it used to be like, if I wrote her an email,
我知道这并不是因为安吉拉不在乎。当然。这并不是因为她不重视我和我们的工作。我知道这完全是由于细节问题。这属于“电子邮件对她不管用”的范畴。所以，当她听了你的节目并找到了让电子邮件为她所用的方法之后，现在我的邮件终于能被看到了。这简直太具变革意义、太令人兴奋了。因为我告诉过安吉拉，以前的情况就好像，如果我给她写了一封电子邮件，
it could be similar to me typing out on a piece of paper, crumbling it up and throwing it out my window. It had like that. That's so bad. I'm so sorry. Like if I wrote her an email, I would need to print it out and run it over to her house. You know what I mean? I'm exaggerating, obviously, but it's like, I knew that this was a system problem.
那感觉就像是我在一张纸上打好字，把它揉成一团，然后从车窗扔出去一样。它给人的感觉就是……太糟糕了。真的非常抱歉。就像如果我给她写了一封邮件，我得把它打印出来，然后一路跑到她家去。你知道我的意思吗？我当然是在夸张，但这就好像，我知道这是一个系统性问题，
This wasn't a caring problem, you know? And that's important too, you know, when you're in a relationship with someone, if you're able to see, like, oh, this doesn't mean this person doesn't care about me or doesn't value me, but our systems are not in sync, but we need to figure something out because we work together. Right. Yeah. And we work really well together
这并不是一个在乎与否的问题，你知道吗？这也是很重要的，你知道的，当你和某人建立某种关系时，如果你能够看清：“哦，这并不意味着这个人不在乎我或不重视我，而是我们的系统不同步，但我们必须想出点办法来，因为我们要在一起工作。”没错。是的。而且我们合作得非常愉快，
and we are really great creative partners. So just some of the tidying of business, I don't know, I had to figure out for myself. And here's what I did. I had listened to a different episode of yours a while back, and it came back to me. It was an episode 254, Chores I Do Every Day. And I am really good at zoning and batching, I am really good at zoning and batching, you know, like in my house. I'm very good with tangible clutter, you know? And so I had remembered that episode when I was listening to five things for more ease at work and I thought, you know what, there's got to be a way that I can zone and batch my
我们是非常棒的创意合作伙伴。所以只需要对业务进行一些微调，我不知道，我必须为自己找到解决办法。以下是我所做的。我前段时间听过你的另一期节目，现在它又浮现在我的脑海里。那是第254集，《我每天都要做的杂务》。我很擅长进行分区和批量处理，我很擅长分区和批量处理，你知道的，就像在我家里那样。我在处理实体杂物方面非常在手，你知道吗？所以当我听到《提升工作轻松感的五件事》那一集时，我就想起了那期节目，心想：你知道吗，肯定有一种方法能让我像处理家里的杂物那样，去对我的
emails the way I do the clutter in my house. So I started watching YouTube videos on how to organize your email. And I forget the fella's name. You only saw his hands. I never really saw his face. But anyway, wherever you are, that guy that made an email video's really helpful. Just your hands. But in Gmail, you can make labels and folders, and you can assign emails that all those email addresses will go into different labels and folders. And I know a lot of you out there listening already know this and you're like, yeah, duh. But I had never done that. So all of my general emails all went into one spot.
电子邮件进行分区和批量处理。于是我开始在YouTube上看关于如何整理电子邮件的视频。我忘了那个小伙子的名字。你只能看到他的手。我根本没看清他的脸。不过，无论你在哪里，制作那个电子邮件视频的家伙真的很有帮助。只有你的手。但在Gmail里，你可以创建标签和文件夹，你可以把那些电子邮件地址指定的邮件归入不同的标签和文件夹。我知道你们很多在听节目的朋友已经知道了，心里会想：这不废话吗。但我以前从来没这么做过。所以我的所有普通邮件全都堆在同一个地方。
And that is every project I'm working on, Office Ladies, our live show, our book, plus anything I'm doing with Baking with Josh and Angie, plus the school, three kids. At one point, I had a kid in elementary. I had two in middle school. Those are two different principles. And oh my gosh, so many emails, plus anything I'm doing outside of this. Like if I was doing a TV show or I was, you know, auditioning for some commercial or all of those emails. And I took a day and I went through and I found all my contacts and I made all these labels and folders. So now I have one that is just office ladies. And what's great is I can look at office ladies.
这就是我正在做的所有项目，Office Ladies、我们的现场秀、我们的书，再加上我跟Baking with Josh and Angie合作的任何事情，还有学校，三个孩子。曾经有一段时间，我有一个孩子上小学，我有两个在上初中。那是两个不同的校长。哦天哪，有那么多的电子邮件，再加上我在这之外做的任何事情。比如如果我在做一个电视节目，或者我，你知道的，在为某个广告试镜，或者所有这些邮件。我花了一天时间，浏览并找到了我所有的联系人，我制作了所有这些标签和文件夹。所以现在我有一个专门是office ladies的。最棒的是我可以查看office ladies。
Like today I can check my office ladies folder. I have no unopened emails guys. Wow. So I might have 2,333 in that big general craziness, but in my office ladies folder, I have zero unopened emails. And yesterday I only had 12. And 12 is a
就像今天我可以检查我的office ladies文件夹一样。我没有未打开的邮件，伙计们。哇。所以我可能在那个巨大的普遍混乱中有2333封，但在我的office ladies文件夹里，我有零封未打开的邮件。而昨天我只有12封。12封是一个
lot easier to find and tackle. And also what I learned is what my business partner needs. I don't need this. I can send you an email and I know Jenna will have read it. And sometimes I don't need an answer. But I think one of the things that Jenna likes is that I read it and I say, got it, let me look that up. If I don't have an answer yet, because I used to not answer an email until I had the answer. And sometimes that process takes a day or two. So then it's two days that Jenna hasn't even heard from me that I've read it. So now I just, I'm very big now on confirmed, received.
更容易找到和处理的数量。而且我学到的另一件事是我商业伙伴需要什么。我不需要这个。我可以给你发一封电子邮件，我知道詹娜会读过它。有时候我不需要答案。但我认为詹娜喜欢的事情之一是我读了它并说，知道了，我去查查看。如果我还么有答案的话，因为我以前不会回复电子邮件，直到我有了答案。有时这个过程需要一两天。所以那是詹娜甚至没有听到我的消息，甚至不知道我读了它的两天时间。所以现在我只是，我现在非常看重确认，收到。
We'll look into it. I have to say, I don't know if you can hear it in Angela's voice, but she's super excited about her emails and her batching. And this enthusiasm, it's like, this is not something that was just for me. This is like a thing that she's excited about now. And so I think that's another reason why it's working, you know, because you talk about your emails all the time now. And so I think that's another reason why it's working, you know, because you talk about your emails all the time now, it's really fun. I'm like, welcome to emails. I really hope someday I don't ever have to send another email, but I'm realizing now that's probably not going to happen.
我们会查清楚的。我必须说，我不知道你能不能在安吉拉的声音中听出来，但她对她的电子邮件和批量处理超级兴奋。这种热情，就像是，这不仅仅是为了我。这就像是她现在感到兴奋的事情。所以我认为这也是它起作用的另一个原因，你知道的，因为你现在一直在谈论你的电子邮件。所以我认为这也是它起作用的另一个原因，你知道的，因为你现在一直在谈论你的电子邮件，这真的很有趣。我就像，欢迎来到电子邮件的世界。我真的希望有一天我再也不用发另一封电子邮件了，但我现在意识到这可能不会发生。
Well, you have named this is a great avatar, such a great example of things that happen in our lives all the time. It's not that you have to just be like, well, oh, well, I got 7,000 unread emails. This is just the way I am. Or that you have to commit to inbox zero at all times, right? There is such a wide middle to most of the problems that we have, and it just comes down to naming. Jenny, you said it so well.
好吧，你已经命名了，这是一个极好的化身，是我们生活中一直发生的很好的事情的绝佳例子。这并不是说你必须表现得像，好吧，哦，好吧，我有7000封未读邮件。我就是这样的人。或者说你必须在任何时候都致力于收件箱清零，对不对？我们遇到的大多数问题都有一个非常广泛的中间地带，而这归根结底就是命名。珍妮，你说的太好了。
It's like, this is not a caring problem. This is a systems problem. I would guess, Angela, that if you're naming what matters to you about email, actually your partnership with Jenna matters more to you than your comfort around the email. Like you're willing to have some discomfort and some like, I hate this, but I'm going to do it because Jenna matters to me more. Yes, that's exactly right.
就像是，这不是一个关心的问题，这是一个系统的问题。我猜，安吉拉，如果你说出对你来说重要的关于电子邮件的事情，实际上你与詹娜的伙伴关系对你来说比你在电子邮件上的舒适感更重要。就像你愿意承受一些不适和一些诸如，我讨厌这个，但我还是会做，因为詹娜对我更重要。是的，完全正确。
So that's the thing. So if you name what really matters about something and almost always when we're in conflict with another person, what matters the most for the people both is connection with each other. Like there's very little that you're gonna put over connection with that person. So it just opens the door to like, okay, what matters the most to you about this?
这就是关键所在。所以如果你说出关于某事的真正重要的东西，几乎在我们与另一个人发生冲突时，对双方来说最重要的是彼此之间的连接。就像没有什么东西会凌驾于与那个人的连接之上。所以这只是打开了一扇门，比如，好吧，关于这个，对你来说最重要的是什么？
What matters the most to me about this? And we can find a way to make this work. You can take the skills that you have in batching and zoning with your clutter. Like you can do that to go like, oh, that's a system that kind of works. Let's see if I can apply some of these same principles to this other thing. Rather than being like, this is the seven step program that I have to follow that this random dude told me to do. You know, like it's, this is just, I love this so much
关于这个，对我来说最重要的是什么？我们可以找到一种方法让它发挥作用。你可以把你杂物分类和分区的技能拿来。就像你可以用它来觉得，哦，那是一个有点用的系统。让我们看看我是否能把这些相同的原则应用到其他事情上。而不是像，这是我必须遵循的七步程序，这个随便哪个老兄让我做的。你知道的，就像是，这只是，我太喜欢这个了
because this is what it's about. It's about naming what matters to you. It's acknowledging what matters to someone else that you care about or you work with or you live with or whatever. And then kind of slowly and kindly finding a way that works for everyone. And now you're excited about email.
因为这就是它的意义所在。它是关于说出对你重要的是什么。它是承认对你关心的、或你与之共事的、或你与之生活在一起的其他人重要的是什么。然后以一种缓慢而友善的方式找到适合每个人的方法。现在你对电子邮件感到兴奋了。
Like what a world, what a world this is. I think it's a stretch to say I'm excited about email. But I am happy to have these folders. Because I like folders, I like putting things in their place. It's like the baskets of the computer. Yes. And you love a basket. I do love a basket. Kendra, you know, when you talk about your papers and all the computer. And you love a basket. I do love a basket.
这是什么世界，这是一个什么样的世界。我认为说我对电子邮件感到兴奋有点夸张。但我很高兴有这些文件夹。因为我喜欢文件夹，我喜欢把东西放在它们该在的地方。这就像电脑里的篮子。是的。你喜欢篮子。我确实喜欢篮子。肯德拉，你知道的，当你谈论你的文件和所有电脑。你喜欢篮子。我确实喜欢篮子。
Kendra, you know, when you talk about your papers and all the papers. So I had, you know, had in our friendship, I had a baby first. And then when it was Jenna's turn, I said, listen, they're gonna give you a lot of papers at the hospital, so many papers. And you're not gonna know where all to put all the papers
肯德拉，你知道的，当你谈论你的文件和所有的文件。所以，你知道的，在我们的友谊中，我先生的孩子。然后当轮到詹娜时，我说，听着，他们在医院会给你很多文件，这么多的文件。而你不会知道把所有的文件都放在哪里
and then you're gonna need them when you leave and there's gonna be stacks of papers. And I gave her a basket. It was a basket that someone had given me a baby gift in at the hospital, like little wash rags and diapers all rolled up in little bows. And I'd taken everything out of it and put all the hospital papers in it.
然后当你离开时你会需要它们，而且会有厚厚一叠文件。我送了她一个篮子。那是别人在医院送给我的婴儿礼物的篮子，里面有小毛巾和尿布，都卷成小蝴蝶结。我把里面所有的东西都拿出来了，把所有的医院文件都放进去了。
And I walked out of the hospital with a basket of papers and I gave Jenna that same basket. I was like, trust me, you're gonna put papers in it. And Jenna, you were so cute. You were like, said to your husband, you're like, Lee, we have to have the basket for papers. I did. Well, Angie, you might not remember this,
我提着一篮子文件走出了医院，我把同样的篮子给了詹娜。我当时就想，相信我，你会把文件放进去的。詹娜，你太可爱了。你当时对你丈夫说，你就像，李，我们必须有一个装文件的篮子。我确实这么做了。好吧，安吉，你可能不记得这个了，
but when I broke my back in New York and they sent me home from the hospital, we got back to the hotel and you were there and people had sent, you know, fruit baskets and cupcake baskets. You dumped everything out of one of those baskets and you put all the hospital papers in it. You did.
但当我背部在纽约受伤，他们让我出院回家时，我们回到了酒店，你在那里，人们送了，你知道的，水果篮和纸杯蛋糕篮。你把其中一个篮子里所有的东西都倒出来了，然后你把所有的医院文件都放进去了。你真的这么做了。
You love a hospital paper basket. I just needed an email basket. That's what I needed. Now you have it. Now you have your email basket. I have it Now you have it. Now you have it. Now you have your email basket. I have it. I have one question for you, Angela.
你喜欢医院文件篮。我只是需要一个电子邮件篮。这就是我需要的。现在你有了。现在你有了你的电子邮件篮。我有。我有一个问题要问你，安吉拉。
Would it bring you great joy if the folders on an email looked like little baskets? Yes. It would. It would. It would. It would be a conagherty. I would like that. Is that a thing?
如果电子邮件上的文件夹看起来像小篮子，会给你带来巨大的快乐吗？是的。会的。会的。这会是一个近藤麻里惠式的时刻。我会喜欢的。这是一回事吗？
Can someone do that for you? Imagine how excited you would be to put things in it. I would be excited to put things in it. And then I'd also be excited when it was empty, like the trash basket on your desktop. I get very excited when I empty it. That would be a tangible gift to me. I think that someone needs to make this because it might transform other people's lives as well.
有人能为你做这个吗？想象一下，你会多么兴奋地把东西放进去。我会兴奋地把东西放进去的。然后当它是空的的时候我也会很兴奋，就像你桌面上的垃圾桶一样。当我清空它时，我感到非常兴奋。这对我有切实的帮助。我认为有人需要做这个，因为它也可能会改变其他人的生活。
If you could pick what the thing is that you put stuff in. Yes. Kendra, thank you so much for coming on this special Monday motivation of Office Ladies today. Everyone, you can find episode 297, Five Things for More E's at Work. And listen to it, maybe it'll transform your life. But Kendra, you also have a new episode out today.
如果你能挑选你用来放东西的东西。是的。肯德拉，非常感谢你来到今天Office Ladies这个特别的星期一动力时刻。各位，你们可以找到297集《工作中的五大轻松秘诀》（Five Things for More E's at Work）并听一听，也许它会改变你的生活。但是肯德拉，你今天也有一集新节目上线。
It's episode 351, and it's called How to Lazy Genius Your Whole Life, which is kind of the perfect episode if you're a new listener. Kendra, you said it's kind of a beginner's guide to the lazy genius, but also a good reminder of the whole reason you're doing this, which is, like you said earlier, you want to make this a lifestyle and a mindset and not just a random choice that we make every once in a while.
它是第351集，叫做《如何用懒人天才法过好你的一生》（How to Lazy Genius Your Whole Life），如果你是一个新听众，这算是一个完美的单集。肯德拉，你说这有点像懒人天才的入门指南，但也是对你做这件事的整个原因的一个很好的提醒，那就是，就像你刚才说的，你想把这变成一种生活方式和心态，而不仅仅是我们偶尔做的一个随意的选择。
You also had a great episode last week called Starting Fresh When You Can't Start Over. It's all about the January pressure to change everything. And your episode is so great because it really encourages people to start small. And that's one of the, there are 13 lazy genius principles that are in my first book that are basically the foundation of everything I talk about. And one of the principles is to start small. And it's the most annoying of all the 13.
你上周也有一集很棒的节目，叫《无法重新开始时如何全新开始》（Starting Fresh When You Can't Start Over）。它完全是关于一月份想要改变一切的压力。你的节目非常棒，因为它真的鼓励人们从小事做起。这是我的第一本书中的13个懒人天才原则之一，它们基本上是我谈论的一切的基础。其中一个原则就是从小事做起。这是所有13个原则中最烦人的一条。
It's so annoying. Nobody wants to start small, including myself. You don't see any progress right away. It just feels like it's not really gonna do anything. But honestly, those small steps over like even a long time, those are the things that stick way more than these big systems that we build over three days in January that then fall apart. So I do love that this is a good reminder of like, hey, we're going to start small
这太烦人了。没有人想从小事做起，包括我自己。你不会马上看到任何进展。感觉它好像不会起什么作用。但老实说，即使在很长一段时间内，那些小步前进，才是比我们在1月份花三天时间建立然后分崩离析的大系统更能坚持下去的东西。所以我确实很喜欢这是一个很好的提醒，那就是，嘿，我们要从头开始
with this. And that is actually going to make it more doable and accessible and probably even work in a way that you want it to work, even though it's annoying, starting small is so annoying, but it really does help. So yeah, I'm excited for y'all to listen to that. Kendra, I have your sticker that says Start Small on my computer. That's so fun. And it's crazy because I lost my computer on a flight. I got off the airplane once and I left my computer on the plane.
带着这个。这实际上会使它更可行、更容易实现，甚至可能以你想要的方式工作，尽管它很烦人，从小事做起是如此烦人，但它确实有帮助。所以，是的，我很高兴你们去听那一集。肯德拉，我的电脑上有你的贴纸，上面写着从小事做起。这太有趣了。而且很疯狂，因为我在一次飞行中弄丢了我的电脑。我有一次下飞机，把电脑落在飞机上了。
And I can't believe it, but Air Canada found it. It had flown to multiple other cities, but they managed to find it. And when they asked me, how can you identify your computer? And I said, it has a sticker on it that says start small. And they said, we found it. We found your computer. Yeah. Oh, that's so great. And it was all because I was so committed
我简直不敢相信，但加拿大航空公司找到了它。它飞往了其他好几个城市，但他们设法找到了它。当他们问我，你如何识别你的电脑时，我说，它上面有一个贴纸，上面写着从小事做起。他们说，我们找到了。我们找到了你的电脑。是的。哦，太棒了。这一切都是因为我如此致力于
to the lazy genius principle of starting small. Yeah, yeah. And I love it. It's a good one for people who are, who skew genius, who lean that way a lot and who are like, let's roll, let's go. Let's get it all done right now. Because we can run that direction until we we fall down sad and crying.
懒人天才从小事做起的原则。是的，是的。我很喜欢。对于那些偏向天才、非常倾向于那种方式、觉得“我们上吧，我们走吧，我们现在就把一切都搞定”的人来说，这是一个很好的原则。因为我们可以朝着那个方向奔跑，直到我们倒下来悲伤哭泣。
Yeah. And so Start Small kind of helps us temper that a little bit. It's like the kindest little break tap. You know, it's like, Hey, let's, we're all right, we're all right. Start Small. Bringing you back to the podcast. That's really why I love this work that I do. Because the 13 principles and the way the Lazy Genius Method, all of these things are really versatile no matter how you operate, no matter how you think, no matter what your life looks like, no matter what season you're in. Like they really are tools for everyone because they're personal and versatile and they work. They are not like self-help steps that only work for a certain kind of person. They're much broader and kinder than that. So it's really fun work to do because it helps anybody who is interested in being helped
是的，所以从小事做起在某种程度上帮助我们稍微缓和了一下。这就像最亲切的小刹车。你知道的，就像是，嘿，我们，我们都很好，我们都很好。从小事做起。把你带回播客。这真的是我热爱我所做的工作的原因。因为13个原则以及懒人天才方法的方式，所有这些事情确实非常多功能，无论你如何运作，无论你如何思考，无论你的生活是什么样子，无论你处于什么季节。它们确实是适合每个人的工具，因为它们是个性化的、多功能的而且它们确实管用。它们不像只对某种特定的人起作用的自助步骤。它们比那更广泛、更友善。所以这是一项非常有趣的工作，因为它帮助任何有兴趣被帮助
and wanting to see their life this way. It really does help. It really does work. So it's such a fun treat to be able to share that with the Office Ladies listeners. This is so fun. Well, you're so, so fantastic at it. We're so thrilled to have you on Office Ladies, and we can't wait for people to hear your episodes.
并且想要以这种方式看待生活的人。它真的很有帮助。它确实管用。所以能与Office Ladies的听众分享这一点真是一件非常有趣的美差。这太有趣了。嗯，你在这方面太、太棒了。我们很高兴你能来到Office Ladies，我们迫不及待地想让大家听到你的节目。
Yeah, we are so excited for you to be joining the Office Ladies Network. Yeah, we're a network. We're a dang network, y'all. Now we are. Yes. I love it. Everybody, please go subscribe to the Lazy Genius and guess what?
是的，我们很高兴你能加入Office Ladies网络。是的，我们是一个网络。我们是一个该死的网络，各位。现在我们是了。是的。我太喜欢了。大家，请去订阅《懒人天才》（The Lazy Genius）吧，猜怎么着？
You will hear us on Lazy Genius next week. That's right. We're going to be your guest. I know. Everybody's in the loser minds. It's so fun. It's so fun. Thank you all so much for having me. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
你们下周会在《懒人天才》上听到我们的声音。没错。我们要去当你们的嘉宾。我知道。每个人都在疯狂。这太有趣了。这太有趣了。非常感谢你们邀请我。感谢收听Office Ladies。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office Ladies由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的高级制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·巴比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。